ก็สวัสดีค่ะพี่แอดตี้สิครับรู้เรียนม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนวันนี้ก็มาเจอกับพี่
อาร์ตี้กับน้องเรียมนะครับในช่องคอม
frenzel ไทยแล้วใครแล้ววันนี้ที่เราเจอ
กันเป็นวันอะไรคะพี่สุวันนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
วันนี้วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ครับ
วันอาทิตย์ตายวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันอาทิตย์ที่ 20 ครับวันนี้
เฮ้อเดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือนมีนาคมครับ
ใส่แล้วแล้วข้อสองอะไรคะปีคศ 2000  22
ใช้ครับข้อสอราคะพ.ศ
ตอนนี้เราคุยกันมีอยู่กี่โมงแล้วคะพี่
อาร์ตี้กี่โมงแล้วครับตอนนี้ไหนดูนาฬิกา
ซิเลียมีนาฬิกาไหมฮ่ากี่โมงแล้วดูนาฬิกา
หน่อย
นาฬิกาของยังไม่มีไม่มีเข็ม
ตอนนี้เลยครับอ่าเดี๋ยวนาฬิกาของพี่
อาร์ตี้ตอนนี้มันเหรอ
9:00 น 9:30 น
ชายสามทุ่มครึ่งแล้วตอนเย็นสั้น
3 ทุ่มเข็มสั้นก็จะอยู่เลข 9 เลยไม่ก้าว
ไปนิดนึงยาว
เลยเลข 9 ไปนิดนึงๆครับเลยไปครึ่งนึง
เจ๊ 3 ทุ่มยาวอยู่ที่ไหนนะคะเออเข็มยาว
อยู่ที่เลข 6 ครับเพราะว่าครึ่งหนึ่งสาม
สิบนาที
21:30 นาทีก็คือ 21:30 นอ่ะ
อ่า
โอเคโอเคแล้วนายครับ
ได้เวลานอนแล้วใช่ไหมคะพี่ก็คือก่อนนม
ก่อนนอนเดี๋ยวฟังฟังเรื่องเล่าก่อนนะฟัง
เรื่องเล่าก่อนดีมั้ยก่อนที่จะไปนอนดีไหม
ครับนักเรียน
ไทยค่ะหรือว่านักเรียนจะนอนแล้วก็ฟัง
เรื่องเล่า 5 นอนฟังดอนฟังใช่ไหมแน่นอน
ฟังนอนฟังก็ได้นะครับโอเคเล่าเรื่องอะไร
ดีครับวันนี้
ถ้าตอบค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ภาคต่อของอะไรครับ
ต่อจากใครที่มั้ยอ๋ออ๋อสไปเดอร์แมนภาคต่อ
จากเขาที่แล้วครับเผื่อที่เล่าไปเขาที่
แล้วเนี่ยเราภาค 1 ใบวันนี้เล่าภาคต่อ
เป็นภาคต่อภาคที่ที่พักที่ 2 ภาคที่ 2
ใช่ค่ะอ่าโอเค
Spiderman ภาค 2 ครับวันนี้
Thailand เป็นยังไงบ้างครับเล่นไง
จำได้ไหมคะครั้งที่แล้วที่
ปีเตอร์
กับแฮร์รี่เป็นเพื่อนกันเออใช่ครับปิด
เตอร์กับแฮร์รี่เป็นเพื่อนกันเพื่อที่จำ
ได้ครับครั้งนี้เตรียมจำได้แล้วว่าเพื่อน
ของปีเตอร์ชื่อแฮร์รี่อ๋อโอเคเหรอทางที่
แล้วเราจำไม่ได้ๆเออ
ก็คือแฮร์รี่
แขนสไปเดอร์แมนมากๆเออใช่ที่แฮร์รี่คิด
ว่าสไปเดอร์แมนไปฆ่าพ่อของแทรี่ใช่ไหม
ครับ
ใช่ค่ะครับเพราะตอนนั้นแทรี่ก็ยังไม่รู้
ใช่แต่ว่าสไปเดอร์แมนก็คือปีเตอร์ใช่ยัง
ไม่รู้
แล้วก็ผ่านไปสองปีประมาณ 2 ปีค่ะพี่
อาร์ตี้
ของทุกคนเรียนจบแล้วก็ทำงาน
แฮร์รี่ก็มีบริษัท
มีบริษัทนะคะแค่นี้ก็เปิดบริษัทใช่ไหม
ครับ
[เพลง]
แฮร์รี่เขาเป็น CEO แล้วหาตอนนี้ครับ
แครีเป็นคนคนรวยใช่ไหมแฮร์รี่เป็นคนรวยมี
เงินเยอะ
พอของแถวนี้ก็มีเงินเยอะแฮร์รี่ก็เลยอ่า
มีบริษัทของตัวเอง
โอเค
ครับแล้วแฮร์รี่กับปีเตอร์ก็อย่ากลับมา
เจอกันขอ
ขับ
แล้วก็ก็มีผู้หญิงอีกคนนึงนะคะ
หรือผู้หญิงกี่คนนึง
ที่เหมือนเป็นเพื่อนกันอีก 5 ปีเตอร์ชอบ
ผู้หญิงคนนี้อ๋อที่เรียนมาด้วยกันใช่ไหม
ตอนที่ที่เรียนมาด้วยกัน
โอเคผู้หญิงคนนี้ชื่ออะไรครับ
ชื่ออะไรครับ
mj อ๋อโอเคชื่อ mj ใช่มั้ยฮะครับ
อินทรี
ตอนนี้ NJ ก็มีชื่อเสียงมีคนคนคนรู้จัก mj
มากๆขอฮึ
แล้วก็สามคนนี้ NJ ปีเตอร์แฮรี่ก็มาเจอ
กันอีกอ๋ออ๋อกลับมาเจอกัน ok ดูหนังแล้ว
ก็มากินข้าวด้วยกันเออครับ
แค่นี่ก็บอกบอกว่ามีบริษัท
เดี๋ยวจะพาปีเตอร์
ไปดูบริษัทเข้าไปดูที่บริษัทครับใช่ค่ะ
หน้าที่บริษัทของปีเตอร์ที่บริษัทของแครี
มีอะไรบ้างครับ
เขาก็ผ่าไปเจอด็อกเตอร์คนนึงอ๋อ
ดอกถ้าคนหนึ่งที่เขาคิดเรื่องแขนกล
หือมีแขนกล
เกือบๆน้องแขนก้น and กลุ่มคนก็คือเป็น
แขนที่ทำมาจากอ่า
ทำมาจากอ่าเครื่องกลจะไม่ใช่แขนของเขาใช่
ไหมไม่ใช่แข็งเขาถ้าเป็นงานที่ผลิตขึ้นมา
ใหม่อ๋ออ๋อเป็นแขนกลโอเค
อายุที่บริษัทของปิดของแฮร์รี่ใช่ไหมครับ
โอเคใช่เหรอ
ด็อกเตอร์ก็เลยลองเอาแขนกลมาใส่
อ๋ออ๋อไม่ใส่ที่ข้างหลังเขาใช่ไหมเพื่อ
ที่มีรูปนะเนี่ยที่มีรูปของดอกเตอร์คนนี้
นี่วันนี้ตอนนี้ใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะใช่
อันนี้ก็คือแขนคนน่ะเป็นแขนที่ไม่ใช่แขน
จริงๆของเขาเป็นแขนที่สร้างขึ้นมาเป็น
เครื่องจักรเครื่องจักรกลคนไทยก็เรียก
สั้นๆเรียกว่าแขนก่อนเอ้อ
ว่าเหมือนแขนไงน่าได้ครับแขนแล้วก็มีมือ
อยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับมีเป็นมือมือนี่ตรง
นี้เป็นแขนตรงนี้เป็นมือเป็นมือ
[เพลง]
เธอครับและก็บอกว่าแขนกลเหมือน AI ที่คิด
ได้ขอแขนกลคิดคิดเองได้ใช่ไหมครับแขนคน
ใช่แล้ว
แต่ว่าเขาก็ใส่คลิปไว้คลิปเล็กๆหรือขับ
บอกว่าคลิปนี้จะควบคุมแขนกลได้โอ๋อ๋อมี
ชิปควบคุมแขนกลอยู่ข้างในอยู่ข้างในอ่ะ
อ่าเครื่องนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วยังไงเขาลองเอาแขนกลมาใส่ข้าง
หลังค่ะ
แขนกลก็ทำงาน
ด็อกเตอร์ก็ควบคุมแขนกลให้หยิบของได้อ๋อ
5 ดีจังมีแขนเยอะเลยครับเธอก็เลยมีแขน
เยอะเลยพี่นี้ถามอาให้นัก
เรียนก็ไม่รู้ทำไม Doctor อยากมีแขนเยอะๆ
อย่าทำงานได้เร็วๆนะครับอ่ามีแขน
เพิ่มอีก 4 แขนหน้าอ๋อใช่
ก็ที่นี้
เขาก็ทำเครื่อง
ฟิวชั่นได้ใช่ไหมคะพี่อาร์ตี้อ๋ออ๋อมี
เครื่องติวชั่นด้วยโอเคอยู่ชายเครื่อง
ฟิวชั่นนี่ทำอะไรได้ครับ
มีเครื่องฟิวชั่นเครื่องเสียงอันนี้ทำ
อะไรครับ
รีบจำได้ว่ามันเป็นเหมือนพระอาทิตย์อัน
นี้ใหญ่อ๋อ
ๆใช้ที่ท่านเพิ่มพลังไหมใช้เพิ่มพลัง
ให้มีพลังเยอะๆ
ใช่คิดว่าเป็นแบบนั้น
พลังเยอะนะครับเราอยากจะทำเครื่องฟิวชั่น
เพิ่มแต่ตอนนี้ยังไม่มีใช่มั้ยตอนนี้ยัง
ไม่มีเครื่องฟิวชั่นไปอยากจะทำให้อ๋ออ๋อ
Doctor อยากจะทำเครื่องฟิวชั่นครับหน้า
แล้วไงต่อครับ
แล้วทำยังไงมันก็เกิดไฟช็อตขึ้นมาอย่าตี 5
ไฟช็อตไฟช็อตให้ครับ
ไปช็อตที่แขนกลขอที่แขนกลไป
ใช่ทำให้ชิดคิดว่าเท่ๆเนี่ยคลิปหรอคลิป
เล็กๆแขนกวนกลุ่มแขนกลโอเคเป็นยังไงครับ
พรุ่งนี้ไปช็อตทางเลยว่าว้าวใช้งานไม่ได้
เลยใช่ไหมครับ
[เพลง]
แขนโกนก็ควบคุม Doctor ขอโทษทีนี้
ด็อกเตอร์ก็ควบคุมแขนกลไม่ได้แล้วเพราะ
ว่า Chip พังแผนคนก็เลยมาควบคุม Doctor
แทนคะ
ใช่ค่ะอ๋อก็เลยคิด
คิดคิดอยากมีพลังมากๆก็อยากมีพลังมากๆอีก
นะครับแล้วทำยังไงครับ
ก็เลยบอกบอก Doctor อันนี้อันนี้แขนกลนะ
เอาแขนกลก็ด็อกเตอร์แขนกลควบ Doctor อยู่
ไปหาเงินมาเยอะๆ
เยอะเออจะได้จะได้เอาเงินไปซื้อไปซื้อ
อุปกรณ์มาทำเครื่องฟิวชั่นใช่ไหมครับขอ
ให้ค่ะเฮ้อแล้วไปหาเงินจากที่ไหนครับที่
นิอยากได้เงินเนื้อที่ธนาคารค่ะอ๋ออ๋อไป
ที่ธนาคาร
ครับไปที่ธนาคารเลยไปทำอะไรที่อ่ะเนาะไป
ปล้น / อาคารไปปล้นธนาคารไม่ได้ไปเบิก
ธนาคารใช่ไหมเอาบัตร SM ไปกดตู้กดตึ๊บๆ
ได้เงินออกมาไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่อันนั้นได้น้อย
เกินไปไปปล้นเลยอ่ะไอ้เปิ้ลเลยเอ้อโอเคบน
ธนาคารเลยร้องวันนั้นป้าเมย์กับปีเตอร์ก็
อยู่ที่ธนาคารอ๋ออ๋อปีเตอร์ไปอยู่ที่
ธนาคาร
ด็อกเตอร์ก็มาปล้นธนาคารพอดี
ใช่
ด็อกเตอร์ก็ก้นธนาคารเออแล้วเป็น
ด็อกเตอร์เข้ามา
ปีเตอร์ก็วิ่งหนี
เธอวิ่งไปเลยปีเตอร์ยังยังไม่สู้กับอ่า
Doctor ใช่มั้ยปีเตอร์วิ่งหนีไปวิ่งหนี
ไปทำไมครับ
ปีเตอร์กลัวอะไรคะขอหยุดขอ
มีปีเตอร์ชุดสไปเดอร์แมนตัวปีเตอร์ไม่
อยากให้ป้าเมย์
ป้าเมย์รู้ว่าปีเตอร์เป็นสไปเดอร์แมนใช่
ไหมไม่อยากให้รู้เราก็เลยวิ่งออกไป
ให้ครับแล้วก็วิ่งออนแล้วก็เอาตอนกลับเขา
ไม่วิ่งนะเขาก็จะปล่อยใหญ่
คลิปนี้ก็ไปเปลี่ยนชุดเป็นสไปเดอร์แมน
แล้วก็กลับเข้ามาเจอ
กับเข้ามาก็ปล่อยใหญ่แล้วก็โหรหนใหญ่เข้า
มาขนใหญ่เขามาขนย้ายเข้ามาทำไมครับ
ก็มาช่วยป้าเมย์อ๋ออ๋อมาช่วยป้าเมนสู้กับ
ดร.ใช่มั้ยเพราะ Doctor กำลังจะพ่นธนาคาร
ใช่
แล้วก็คือ
อยากได้เครื่องฟิวชั่นมา
กับเอาตัวปุเป็นต้นธนาคารแล้วก็ได้
เครื่องฟิวชั่นมาแต่ว่าเครื่องฟิวชั่น
ต้องใช้แร่
แรกชื่อแรกที่เที่ยงขอตอนนี้ได้เงินมาทำ
เครื่องฟิวชั่นแล้วแต่ยังไม่เสร็จยังไม่
เสร็จต้องใช้แรกอ้าแรกที่เที่ยวใช่ไหมอ๋อ
และที่เทียมเป็นยังไงครับ
แรกเป็นแร่เป็นแร่ที่ที่ให้พลังงานใช่ไหม
ต้องใช้แรกนี้ด้วยเหรออ๋อเป็นแร่ธาตุที่
ขุดบริษัทดินใช่ไหมหาแล้วเอาที่ไหนครับไป
เอาแรกจากที่ไหนมาครับไปเอาจากแฮร์รี่ค่ะ
อ๋ออ๋อที่บริษัทของแทรี่มีแร่ที่เที่ยง
อยู่สิไหม
ฮือออ The  Doctor ก็ไปหาแฮรี่แล้วก็บอก
ขอแรกที่เที่ยวม.มไม่ขอแรกที่เทียมจาก
แทรี่แล้วแฮร์รี่แฮร์รี่ให้ไหมครับแฮรี่
ให้ไหม
แฮรี่ยังไม่ให้ผมไม่ให้จะบอก Doctor ว่า
ไปจับตัวสไปเดอร์แมนมาโอ๋
เขาจะให้แรกที่เที่ยงอ๋อเขาสไปเดอร์แมนมา
แล้วเอาแรกที่เทียมไปแรกกันเอามันแรกกัน
ใช่
ด็อกเตอร์ก็เลยออกไป
ไปจับสไปเดอร์แมนมาใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะเครียดที่คิดว่าเตรียมคนเรียกว่า
ดอกเตอร์หรือว่าออกเขาเขามีชื่อใช่ไหม
ครับด็อกเตอร์คนนี้ล็อกเกอร์คนนี้เขามี
ชื่อใช่ไหมครับอ่าชื่อว่าชื่อว่าอะไรนะ
ครับดร
เอ่อออก tobias ออกตะเวียสโอเคแล้วตอนที่
เขาถูกแขนกลควบคุมถูกแขนกลควบคุมเออเขา
เปลี่ยนชื่อใหม่เลยนะเปลี่ยนชื่อเป็นอะไร
ครับ
เปลี่ยนชื่อเป็น of ปุ๊ดเปลี่ยนชื่อเป็น
of  food ตอนที่ตอนที่มีแขน of  purpose
Of  persia ตี้คิดว่าคุณคุ้นๆเหมือนกับ
ปลาหมึกปลาหมึกที่มีไง shirt อ๋อมีแขน
เยอะๆเป็นหมึกเฮ้ยจำง่ายและเทคนิคจำง่าย
และเป็น Doctor  of  food ล่ะโอเคสิริออฟ
ฟู้ดก็จะไปไปจับสไปเดอร์แมนใช่ไหมไปจัด
Spiderman กับให้แล้วเราก็ไปสู้กับไงคะ
อ๋อ
กันรถไฟค่ะพี่เอ็ดดี้ครับอันนี้เป็นรถไป
ใช่ไหมอ่ะ
ต่อไป
เราก็ไปสู้กันสู้กันในรถไฟครับ
ล็อกเกอร์ปู๊ดก็ไปเร่งความเร็วโอ้โหทำให้
รถไฟวิ่งวิ่งเร็วๆใช่ไหมวิ่งเร็วเลยไป
วิ่งเร็วมากหรือครับแล้วเขาก็โยนคนนะเขา
มีมือมีมือหลายมือจับคน
สั่งคนในรถไฟนะคะ
กับคนไปไหนครับ
เที่ยงออกมาโชว์จับคนยนต์รถไฟนะครับโยน
ไว้นอกรถไฟขอแล้วเป็นยังไงครับคนเป็นไง
ครับออกมานอกรถไปแล้ว
คุณก็จะตกในคะพี่ตกรถ
แล้วจะไปเดอร์แมนทำไงครับคนกำลังจะตกแล้ว
อ่าแล้วแม่ก็เลยปล่อยใหญ่ขอไปยายไปไปจับ
คนเอาไว้ใช่ไหมจับคนเอาไว้ดึงคนเข้ามาหรอ
ไม่ตกรถไฟ
อันนี้ก็คือเขาจะปล่อยใหญ่ไปหรือ
ก็ใหญ่ไปแล้วคนก็จะมาจุ๊บอยู่ที่ใหญ่ขอ
ให้มันยายืนอยู่ที่ใหญ่ไม่ตกลงไปไม่ตาย
โอเคไม่ตายหรือใช่แล้วก็เอาแต่พูดนี้ก็ทำ
ให้รถไฟเนี่ยวิ่งเร็วๆใช่ไหมคะเออใช่แล้ว
ใส่วิ่งเร็วอยู่มันก็มาที่
ตรงนี้ไม่มีหลานไม่มีรางรถไฟก็คือสุดทาง
แล้วสุดทางแล้ว
ใช่สุดทางแล้วใช่ไหมครับเขไม่มีรางรถไฟ
แล้วเขาก็พูดก็กระโดดออก
จะออกจากรถไฟแล้วขอรถไฟนี่ใส่ก็วิ่งมาถึง
ตรงนี้และล้างข้างหน้าเนี่ยไม่มีและอ๋อ
โอเคอ่ะแล้ว
ออกจะพูดก็ก็โดนออกจากรถไฟหนีไป
ทำยังไงคลิป
เขาก็ปล่อยใหญ่ก็ใหญ่เสร็จตึกตอนนี้
สไปเดอร์แมนอยู่ตรงนี้สไปเดอร์แมน Spider
Man ซิ่ง EP หน้ารถไฟครับ
ใช่แล้วก็มันจะมีตึก
ตึก
เยอะมากๆมิตึกอยู่ข้างทางรถไฟใช่ไหม
ใช่มี
ตึกจู่ๆตรงนี้เป็นรถไฟนะครับอ่านี่รถไฟก็
จะมีตึกอยู่ตรงนี้
เลิกอยู่ข้างๆนิตึกอยู่สองคือ
แล้วสบายได้มันก็อยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ่ะ
ถ้า
ใช่ก็ไปใหญ่ไปใหญ่มายึดกับตรงนี้ไปยายัง
ไงกันตรงนี้ไม่ให้รถไฟวิ่งไปตรงนี้
อ๋อ
โอเคใยปล่อยใหญ่มากๆแล้วก็ดึง
ดึงใยไว้ดึงใหญ่เออนี่เบียร์ที่มีรูปนี้
ไปเดอร์แมนกำลังปล่อยใหญ่เอาไว้ข้างๆสอง
ข้างแล้วก็ดึงดึงไม่ให้รถไฟไปข้างหน้า
เพราะว่าข้างหน้าไม่มีไม่มีรางเเล้วไปไม่
ได้
ขอให้แล้วสุดท้ายเขาก็หยุดได้นะหยุดรถไฟ
ได้อีกได้พอดีเด้อทุกคนก็ไม่เป็นอะไร
แต่ว่าสไปเดอร์แมนก็หมดแรง
เออหมดแล้ว
ครับเอาตะปูก็จับตัว Spider  Man
ทำให้แฮร์รี่โอ้โหก็เลยจับตัว Spider  Man
ได้เพราะสไปเดอร์แมนสู้ไม่ได้แล้วสบาย
หรือไงหมดแล้ง
ใช่แล้วก็ Audi ก็ได้ตัวสไปเดอร์แมนไป
โอ้โหแฮร์รี่ก็เลย
เออโอเคได้ตรวจสไปเดอร์แมนมาแล้ว
และเขาก็เลยถอดหน้ากาก Spiderman ออกเออ
ครับก็เลยรู้
รู้ว่าสไปเดอร์แมนคือ
ปีกเออเออก็ตอนนี้แครีก็ได้รู้แล้วว่า
เพื่อนของตัวเองเพื่อนของตัวเองที่ชื่อ
ปีเตอร์เนี่ยเป็นสไปเดอร์แมนหนอ
แล้วเขาก็เสียใจอยากเห็นเขาร้องไห้นะลอง
ให้เขาร้องไห้ทำไมร้องไห้ครับอย่า
เสียใจรักเพื่อนรักพ่อหรือแต่ว่าเพื่อน
ฆ่าพ่อขอใช่เพราะว่าปีเถอะเออแฮร์รี่
แฮร์รี่คลิปว่าปีเตอร์คิดว่าสไปเดอร์แมน
แฮร์รี่คิดว่าสไปเดอร์แมนฆ่าพ่อของเขา
เธอ
แล้วตอนนี้แครีรู้แล้วว่าสไปเดอร์แมนคือ
ปีเตอร์สไปเดอร์แมนคือเพื่อนของเขาเขาก็
เลยเสียใจใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะต่อปีเตอร์ก็บอก Carry ว่าหยุดก่อน
เดี๋ยวเราคุยกันทีหลังเออตอนนี้ยังไม่คุย
ตอนนี้ยังไม่คุยไม่กลับมาคุยกันก็จะไปใช่
ก็จะไปจับเอาตูดก่อนโหต้องไปกลับเข้าทุก
พุธก่อนเค
เราออกก็ปู๊ดก็ไปทำเครื่องโมชั่นขับแล้ว
ก็ได้แรกที่เที่ยงไปได้แล้วเฮ้อครับ
ใช่หรือแล้วทีนี้ปีเตอร์
ก็ไป
ไปแล้วก็ไปดึงสายไฟ
[เพลง]
ดินสายไฟออกมามันจะมีเครื่องใช่ไหมคะ
คอร์ดเรื่องฟิวชั่นมันจะมีตายไฟกลับ
เธอก็ไปดึงสายไฟออกมา
ล็อคเครื่องก็ช้อป
เครื่องช็อตอีกแล้วใช่ไหมครับทำรถชน
Doctor นะ
ด็อกเตอร์ยังไปยังใส่แขนกลอยู่ใช่ไหมครับ
เราด็อกเตอร์ก็เลย
มีสติ
หนอ
ก็รู้แล้วว่าตัวเองทำไม่ดีหรอก็เพราะว่า
เพราะว่าตัวเองไม่รู้ไม่รู้ว่าโดนเครื่อง
แขนกลควบคุมควบคุมให้ทำไม่ดีให้ชายนะแต่
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ด็อกเตอร์รู้และรู้ตัวแล้ว
อย่ารู้สึกตัวแล้วใช่ใช่กับสไปเดอร์แมนก็
เลยมาถามถาม Doctor ว่าคำยังไงเครื่อง
ฟิวชั่นถึงจะพังขอจะหยุดจะหยุดไม่ให้
เครื่องฟิวชั่นทำงานใช่ไหมเออจะหยุดใน
เครื่องกูชั่นทำงานต้องทำยังไง
สไปเดอร์แมนไม่รู้สไปเดอร์แมนไม่รู้ว่า
ต้องทำยังไงก็เลยถามถาม Doctor ใช่มั้ย
เออแล้วก็เพิ่มบอกว่ายังไงครับต้องทำยัง
ไงดอกเตอร์บอกมั้ง
Doctor บอกว่าต้องเอาเครื่องฟิวชั่น
ลงไปในน้ำอ๋อ
เอาทิ้งลงไปในน้ำมาเครื่องจะได้หยุดทำงาน
หรอทิ้งลงไปในน้ำฮะโอเคให้เราด็อกเตอร์ก็
บอกว่าเดี๋ยวด็อกเตอร์จะเป็นคนเอาเครื่อง
ฟิวชั่นทิ้งลงไปในนา
โอเคเขาก็ใช้แขนกล
แขนกลทางเครื่องเกี่ยวชั่นแล้วก็ลงไปใน
น้ำ
ลงไปทุกอย่างก็
หาลงไปน้ำทั้ง Doctor ทั้งแขนกลทั้ง
เครื่องฟิวชั่นลงไปน้ำหมดเลยขอหมดเลย
ด็อกเตอร์ก็ตายอ๋อพัดลงไปในน้ำเครื่องก็
พังด็อกเตอร์ก็จมน้ำจมลงไปในน้ำใช่ไหมจม
น้ำตาย
ลืมจำไม่ได้ว่าเครื่องระเบิดได้ไหมระเบิด
ประตู
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้เตรียมคิดว่าระเบิดนะลงไป
แล้วก็ระเบิดตูมเรา Doctor สไตล์ด้วยอะ
The  Fusion ต้องคันด้วย
โอเคก็เลยจบแค่นี้ใช่ไหมถ้ายจบตอนจบแฮร์
รี่แฮร์รี่ลี
แคทปีเตอร์มากแล้วก็
ปีเตอร์ใช่ไหม
เราบ้านก็พังจบแครีก็เจอชุดครีมพริตติ้
นท์เออ Green ก๊อปปิ้นที่ที่พ่อพี่กอล์ฟ
เตอร์ฮีตคองบินที่พอกที่พ่อของแฮร์รี่ใส่
ใช่ไหม
ใช่โอ๋
จบภาค 2 ก็จบแค่นี้ภาค 2 โอเคว้าว
เป็นยังไงบ้างคะสนุกไหมครับนักเรียนนัก
เรียนยังทานก่อนนอนนอนไปแล้วนักเรียนนอน
หลับไปแล้วหรือยังฟังอยู่แล้วตอนนี้คือ
นักเรียนตื่นครับตื่น
แล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าคราวหน้าอ่าน้องเรียน
อาจจะเอา Spiderman ภาค 3 มาเน่าให้ฟังอิ
ชิ
ดีไหมตากไหมอยากดูหนังเรื่องสไปเดอร์แมน
มีภาค 3
มีอีกใช่ไหมชายชายเพชรพี่รู้ว่ามีอีก
ใช่นะหรือถ้านักเรียนอยากฟังเรื่องอะไร
อ่ะ
หรือถ้านักเรียนอยากฟังเรื่องอะไรนะครับ
ขี้ใส่มาในคอมเม้นต์ได้นะครับหน้าเดี๋ยว
เราอาจจะไปหามาถ้าเทียบที่เคยดูถ้าน้อง
เรียมเคยดูเดี๋ยวหรอมันเล่าให้ฟังกันนะ
ครับใช่อือ
สำหรับวันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมคะพี่อ่า
ใช่ครับหมดเวลาแล้วนะครับเดี๋ยวเรากลับไป
เจอกันใหม่คราวหน้านะครับว่าจะเป็นเรื่อง
อะไรไปก่อนแล้วค่ะครับผมอ่ะก็สวัสดีครับ
นักเรียน
นักเรียนบ๊ายบาย
หนัง xxx